we think that knowledge is an endless
accumulation there you just you add to
what came before which we do and it just
it never goes away you keep adding more
and more and more and it builds up and
it's all getting greater and greater
obviously not quite true we think that
these silly people from the 17th century
or the medieval folks or whatever they
are just not as smart as we are that
that's why they forgot these things
that's why they lost the recipe for
concrete they lose it they must have
been you know idiots so we think that
we're wiser than people were in the past
as Donald Rumsfeld would say these are
the unknown unknowns when something is
forgotten
we're unaware that it is just so we have
no knowledge that oh we lost the recipe
for concrete maybe we see this Doman we
go oh man how did they do that but we
don't know but we don't we don't know
that what's missing because because it's
missing abandonment letting a knowledge
or technology go is a kind of filter
might not be a good filter but sometimes
it might be a necessary filter
rediscovery then which is also selective
is another filter so things are getting
filtered now twice we find the future
our own future the future of everyone
sometimes we find it in the past rather
than looking at the here and now and
looking forward and we should maybe turn
around and see what happened before that
we missed
so to go forwards sometimes we first
have to go back that's the end
[Applause]